- What's up, everyone, and
welcome back to the final week of the B/R
Gridiron Punishment League.
Your champions of it all,
FlemLo and Jack.
This week's losers are Amanda and Lou.
Lou, you look upset.
- I'm a little hurt about my team.
You play to win the game.
You guys won.
Congrats to you guys.
- Appreciate it, Lou.
- Who let you down this week
besides Lou?
- Actually, Lou came in third place.
- No, you didn't.
- You came in last. Every time I got punished, you were underneath.
- [Laughing]
- And Amanda selected their punishment.
They will be completing the
cinnamon challenge.
- I love cinnamon,
but I've never tried the challenge.
- I can already see the cinnamon
filling up Lou's screen.
- I might have to back up here.
- This is the final punishment.
Amanda, would
you like to start the punishment yourself,
donate it to Lou?
- Ladies first,
- I think we should do it together.
- I'm a little scared right now.
I'mma be honest with you.
- That's why you wore the helmet, Lou?
- Just in case, man.
- I never seen y'all so
nervous before a challenge, bruh.
- I'm actually shaking.
- This is high stakes.
- All right, Lou.
- Let's do it.
- To an incredible season
- We stink at fantasy football.
- Three, two, one. Swallow.
- [Coughing]
- He gotta go, Lou gotta go with a
bigger scoop, man.
- Oh!
- Oh, here we go.
- Amanda's blowing—
- Cinnamon clouds!
- It looks like Lou might've bodied it.
- He got the ceylon cinnamon.
- C'mon, man, this is the real deal.
- Real talk.
- Lou, there's no way.
- Look at Amanda.
- My eyes are burning. It's spicy as hell.
- I'm sweating.
- You're full of it.
- Look at Amanda. She's goin'
through it.
- They fell apart in crisis, man.
- Lou, did you even blow any cinnamon out?
- I just coughed a little bit,
but we all good.
- I just blew cinnamon all over this hotel.
- Let's talk about our favorite moments
from this incredible season.
FlemLo,
you were the least punished.
But what was your favorite
punishment of it all?
- I'mma go with Lou with the
"Leave the Door Open" remix, man.
- Come on, man!
- Do you still remember any of the lyrics?
- [Singing] Y'all gon' have to get open.
[Singing] Y'all gon' have to get open.
- Amanda, what was your favorite?
- It's probably the chicken wings,
because even though there were
footballs taped to my hand,
I love chicken wings.
- My favorite,
I liked the hot dogs, but
I liked going through the eggs with FlemLo.
We had a good partnership.
They were doing us dirty,
and we got through that.
- The pumpkin was the worst.
That was disgusting.
- Yeah, I forgot about that pumpkin.
- Well, when you get punished like five
or six out of the eight weeks, Lou,
I guess it's tough to remember 'em all.
- To me,
I consider those trophies. One, two,
three, four, five.
- Unbelievable season with you all.
Hopefully, we get to do it again
sometime soon.
Signing off for one final time.
I'm Jack. That's Amanda. That's Lou.
That's FlemLo.
And this was the B/R
Gridiron Punishment League.